so
this is
ibo but her name's stella jenna made a
video about this so check it out on her
channel and farook was also making a
video about this who we haven't
introduced you to yet but you guys all
know him for come join us
what are we doing it is very confusing
but today we thought that we would have
the meats and we'd all go hang out and
just
do dog things both of ours have the same
eye color too so we're like looking for
any identifying objects stella has a
little scuff on her nose from her first
time at my house she face planted
totally my fault if you guys want i have
some callers that don't really work with
maddie so we could put them on we'll
know who's going so we didn't have this
one thank you for mango i got these in
rome
braggy stella is this you yes this is
you oh this is cute maybe my colors
thinks that this is for him because he
loves collars
maddie i'm sorry you didn't get a
necklace maddie do you feel left out do
me put a collar on you i'm gonna get him
a caller i didn't want him to feel left
out oh man of course you're gonna get
your tiffany you're gonna get this one
your beautiful boy i don't want you to
feel left over he's like very excited
about this
hi stella
okay what do we do now guys well i guess
we should i'm hungry
i'm hungry too are you guys hungry are
you hungry maddie i did feed stella
birthday cake um in the app
i gave her a birthday cake and then she
started singing happy birthday
i don't know if she's singing it to
herself but
this is all a lot for me stella has
mostly been at jenna's house she's a
very good girl she her personality went
from being
curious to shy stella take a picture
so it's interesting how she turned to
find people to take the picture of yeah
i wanted you to take a photo of your
friend but that's
[Music]
somebody was quicker to draw for happy
birthday like when she peed on the
carpet you're supposed to be like no
when they do bad things like you're
supposed to be like no bad and when
they're good you're supposed to be like
good girl good good boy it's crazy it's
really weird i'm so i'm so uncomfortable
i'm also hungry let's go okay yeah
should we take them we'll go get some
okay come on let's go you guys gonna go
out i'm gonna go outside can you go
outside
he's got his collar
[Music]
stella
come on stella stand up get up
see this is why i wanted you to bring a
carrier i'm sorry i didn't have one
going very fast come on stella let's go
get up come on be a good girl
come on
wake up let's just pick her up she's
going to sleep
come on stella
oh i'm so sorry
[Music]
so
so we're at lunch right now and stella
and mango are meeting
they met at the house but this is like
their time out like this is their first
date
don't back it up too far
although everyone says they haven't
fallen off the table yet no i'm actually
really impressed when they're going
forward they know because they have two
sensors on the chest and then one sensor
on the nose they understand
they're on a on a surface hi mango you
good boy
good
boy people are definitely like everyone
everyone has that second take and then
they're really confused
well i think we definitely should take
them to the pet store jenna wants to get
a little custom name tag
you should get one too
yeah custom name tags we should maybe
give them a little outfit because it's
kind of cold even though you know it's
los angeles i'm chilly
yeah let's go okay
[Music]
let's go to the passenger but sure i
can't say the word pedstron restaurant
let's go to the pet store i wonder if
they have any
little
treats for robot dogs
hello
[Music]
do you have
anything for robot dogs
let's tell a real food you can't have
look this is real food this is what your
brother eats well this brand
oh oh celeb oh geez wow okay mango what
are you doing
[Music]
mango come on we gotta go
let's go we're gonna go
you can't eat anything here it's it's
not real it's well it's real food but
not for you
[Music]
going to get a custom stella name cast
okay stella we're gonna go to petco
mango you're still you're not
are you okay
the thing with robot dogs you have to
turn them on what they're robots well
we're gonna go into petco
let's go guys let's go see what we can
find i'm gonna ask for a
waterless uh grooming for my dog because
stella needs a little bit of a rinse but
she can't get wet because i'm like
brought her circuit board good girl good
girl do they do waterless it says puppy
baths
do you want to put her in here not
supposed to put pets in there
it says no children
it's fine come on stella we're going to
get you something to wear because you're
cold i bet stella would love this jean
jacket
oh my god is this beautiful this is
actually i want to get this for the for
my
this isn't my real dog it's actually
it's real but do you think that maddie
would like this no he doesn't ever wear
clothes okay oh i think her leg is stuck
in the wire
she'll figure it out
[Music]
here good girl stella let's go see if we
can get you an outfit do you want to get
something mango is very free spirited
oh do you think they have this in my
size
can
we
even
i'm definitely getting this dress for
her this is fall too wait it's winter
i don't know doesn't matter
that sucks
do you like this
what do you think of these dog beds
stella oh there's a nice pink one down
here for you
let's go this is what it's like with
maddie as well good girl come on
just whatever i'll get it myself
look how nice this is
yes you are you're such a good girl
i'll put you in it let's put you in
there
good girl you like that it's soft
it's soft isn't it
is it is she yawning
okay stella i'm gonna get this okay oh
it's okay come on
let's go good girl did you find anything
for for mango almost almost okay
i hope it fits her
i think it will you're you've got a thin
frame
you're i okay it's okay
you're fine you're okay
what do you want
good girl good sit
good sit very good
she must know that we're the pet store
and she's performing
you're getting to know me
because you've been with jenna for a
while
we're bonding
[Music]
oh good pups hello this is my friend
stella
she's not she's not real
i did
oh no she's waking up
oh stella it's okay
trying to pay for your
pay try and pay for your items this is
stella it's okay it's okay
it's okay
it's a friend it's a friend yep
[Music]
we did that
yeah yeah
[Music]
so what have you done to our other dog
stella she's freaking beautiful
yeah i know you're cool ready for the
winter time this is the petco fall
collection do you think she's a little
confused because her sensors are getting
covered up she's probably confused for a
lot of reasons
oh what a little bit of mango oh my gosh
oh no that's a very accurate
they don't like it
[Music]
very unsure
boys yeah but look at stella over here
looking fly
maddie has not moved
he either has mango they
it's like maddie's sensors are blocked
your sensor's blocked
did mango just make that noise yep
he's upset he's not happy
stella is loving life
good girl
okay i'm sorry
i'm starting to feel like she's a real
dog pal i know it gets to you oh god i
just got a lick but a real real dog
nope we missed it
i'm so impressed
let me show you guys what these dogs
can't do and our real dog can okay phil
is happy see she can play music too come
here
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
a real musical time here okay well
that's something we definitely have done
thank you guys for watching this video
be sure to check out jenna's video and
for when you will see your video
very soon very soon i will put
everyone's links in the description
below make sure you check them out
um this is something that we've done
[Music]